firefighting is one of the best
adventures you could ever undertake
takes a lot of commitment and a lot of
heart but you never know what's going to
happen next to me that's what makes a
good adventure when you're on the front
line of one of nature's fiercest forces
you're seeing mother nature up close in
it it's really incredible it's
awe-inspiring it's otherworldly in the
morning the fires laying down the smoke
is rising sun is shining through the
smoke creating these beautiful light
rays and everything is calm and then
once it gets hotter and drier the winds
pick up and you start noticing the fire
start to come alive and next thing you
know it can be running through the trees
sounding like a freight train
it's just amazing you feel so small and
helpless when these trees 150 feet tall
are burning all around you let's get
taught men and women who joined fire
crews and fight fire all summer fit in
my personality like a glove they're
hard-working they love the outdoors they
love the camaraderie of being with
others and they'll have a taste for
adventure they don't mind being dirty
and grubby and smoky and going for days
and days without a shower they have a
thirst for adventure and they love it
it's a big job it's a fun job yet to
come out here and play with fire yeah
I've been in situations where it was
very hot and their homes bring down all
around me and it's a scary thing because
usually you always know a place you can
go to where there's nothing burning but
I was on the street and there were homes
burning everywhere there was no cold
side so to speak there was no way I can
back away from and that was when I
decided it was time to leave I got my
pictures that I needed and it was time
to move on the people who do it they
love it
it's something that isn't unlike
anything else
and you're going to be seeing things
that could be the highlight of your life
it's an incredible adventure it's
something well we're doing